boxer gervented Davis we have the same
last name uh was arrested for domestic
violence and spent 44 days in jail the
charges against him were later dropped
but he still will have to live with the
stigma of being accused of domestic
violence the Maryland Police Department
released a video of Davis's arrest which
showed him being uncooperative with the
police he was initially sentenced to 90
days of house arrest but he violated the
terms of his sentence and was sent to
jail
professional Combat Sports athletes are
held to a higher standard of conduct
than the general public and they can be
prosecuted even if they do not get into
a major altercation with anyone cases
like Davis's should be studied by other
members of the police force so they can
learn to handle these situations in a
safe and effective manner so pull the
footage get anything on your family here
I'm at my house
what's your name
what
is your first name yeah okay
on December 27 2022 the Broward County
Sheriff received a desperate 9-1-1 call
from a woman who expressed fear for her
life she reported being punched in the
face by her live-in boyfriend during an
argument the suspect was identified as
the renowned undefeated professional
boxer gervanta Davis
remember Pizza address I need to send
units to you I need the address
all right
so there's a couple things I wanted to
point out from this clip one
does it make sense that a boxer was
beating his wife and all she had was a
bruise on her lip
think about it this guy is trained to
punch people
if he wanted to punch the woman
wouldn't she be knocked out and the
other question I have is what brought
this anger out of him if he allegedly
punched her because what women do a lot
of the time is they taunt a guy they hit
him first and a lot of times the the lit
is from them trying to get the woman
away from them
and a lot of times their their abuse is
from the men trying to get the woman off
of them
but
the officers I don't think handled the
situation accordingly but I'll tell you
why I think men have an innate instinct
to protect women and I think women know
this and use it against the men and so
you'll see he said why is he getting
arrested and the officer said he's
stronger now the reason that the officer
said that is because under the Duluth
model it's typically
um and I can't remember the actual
wording but the Duluth model switched
the way that police do policing in
around the 80s and what this did was
basically assuming women the stronger
person has power and is trying to use
that against the weaker person the
person that is stronger which is
typically men is the person that is seen
to be the abuser that's why you see
these men that call the police and then
the women
um end up the men will call the police
on the women and then the men get
arrested like we've seen case after case
after case of this
um and the reason is you know feminists
have infiltrated the legal system the
justice system the police system and
they really switched the way that laws
are written and they have implemented
laws that discriminate against men you
see it in the court system too you know
around the same time period they
switched it to where the caregiver that
spends more time with the kid
automatically gets custody well
um if a guy wasn't protecting and
providing for his family then he would
be the demon but if he does it then he's
punished and you'll see these laws that
might not necessarily you know say a
gender but it's very easy to imply who
it is you know are there occasional
women that are stronger than Venture but
by and large who who's going to be
discriminated against um for switching
to the Duluth model
um
so and the other thing I wanted to point
out was he didn't want his daughter to
be outside because he didn't want to see
what was going on I think personally so
I really I I think the officers really
need to be trained on female nature
I I think that this would help I think
that they need to get rid of the Duluth
model I think it doesn't make sense I
think we've really got to start thinking
through does it make sense that a boxer
and we see all of these women coming out
with abuse allegations against Fighters
uh really
like they
they hit you really
a boxer
um yeah and again when women get angry
we just follow our feelings so if we
feel like we're beat in that moment if
we feel like we're being abused that's
what we say and the issue is we have all
this propaganda and all of this legal
jargon that backs us up in a legal
system that'll back us up and it'll just
allow us to live in this delusion and it
doesn't
and unfortunately now we see men's
careers and lives being ruined based on
a system and in my opinion discriminates
against men so
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments
um how do you think the officer could
have handled this situation better and
tell me more what your thoughts are on
the Duluth model and and how we can
improve the criminal justice system but
let me know what you guys think guys
like the video on your way out also
please please please guys buy my merch I
want to walk around and just see people
with these t-shirts that say women
shouldn't vote I think would be so funny
so like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time